[Music]
after a great year in videogames we can
only expect to see even bigger and
better gaming experiences as we make our
way through 2020 so today we've rounded
up some of the most anticipated titles
that are coming to the PlayStation 4 and
PlayStation 5 this year to help you
decide what will join your collection
announced at the 2019 game awards
Gearbox's God fall as a third person
melee action RPG that is set to release
on the PlayStation 5 in this a RPG
players can choose to play solo or in
groups up to three via multiplayer co-op
not much else has been revealed other
than a playstation blog post describing
some of its all new looter slasher
mechanics with plans for a holiday 2020
release playstation also says to look
out for more information about God fall
coming this spring based on a
free-to-play mobile RPG granblue fantasy
vs. utilizes the same universe and its
characters and throws him into a 2d
fighting game developed by Arc System
Works this will be the series first
outing onto home consoles and its first
appearance in North America since the
original III 2019 announcement eleven
characters have been announced with more
coming to the roster via future DLC
brand blue Fantasy Versus comes to ps4
on February 6th
throughout 2019 you may have caught wind
of a little creative game called dreams
during its early access period in 2019
fans began creating their very own video
games as well as remaking classics such
as the original Resident Evil that's
because dreams allows you to create a
game animated movie and soundtrack from
the ground up using an extensive Creator
tool kit after overwhelmingly positive
feedback from the early access build
dreams developer Media Molecule
announced up a game is releasing on
February 14th coming exclusively to the
PSV Arc
you'll be able to suit up as one of
Earth's Mightiest Heroes in this new and
original Iron Man adventure face off
against an anti corporate hacker who's
determined to topple Starks Empire by
using a vast assortment of customized
armor and abilities the game's
announcement trailer shows how your VR
headset can imitate Tony's in helmet UI
as you fly through the atmosphere
utilizing Iron Man's iconic arsenal and
virtual reality players will fight to
defend starts various locations and no
doubt save the world
Ironman VR is set to be released on
February 28th after decades of waiting
Final Fantasy 7 remake is coming to the
ps4 the iconic Square Enix RPG has had
its fair share of rumors surrounding a
remake since the early 2000s when
announcements were made for the ps2
however the project went cold and it
wasn't until III 2015 where the reveal
trailer announced the official ground-up
remake using the Unreal 4 engine Square
Enix also announced an official release
date of March 3rd 2020 which is 23 years
after the original release and from what
we've seen so far it's looking to be
worth the wait only a year after the
release of Team ninjas Neil in 2017 a
sequel was announced at e3 2018 while
it's a sequel in name it will actually
take place before the events of the
first game and like the previous games
re-release phase a playable demo was
released in 2019 which showed off new
enemies yokai powers and the ability to
customize your own protagonist based on
official survey results of the demo it
seems fans are quite excited about an
upcoming sequel team ninjas creative
director Tom Lee assured fans that all
feedback was well received and more
improvements will be made so prepare
your thumbs for more big bosses evil
spirits and even
some rolling cats because neo2 comes to
ps4 on March 13th
previously released only in Japan
personify royal is the complete and
enhanced edition of the 2016 original
this updated version adds ps4 pro
supported 20 new music tracks a new
phantom thief an all-new 3rd semester
and much more
much like persona 4 golden is the
complete package for both newcomers and
veterans of the original game and if you
want to go all-out a phantom thief's
collector's edition was announced the
bundle includes a dynamic ps4 a themed
joker mask art book soundtrack and a
steelbook case personify royal launches
on March 31st hunt or be hunted the
choice is yours predator hunting grounds
is an immersive asymmetrical shooter
coming exclusively to the ps4 on April
24th your mission as the predator is
simple stock and study the Warriors in
the forest as you take them down one by
one while collecting a trophy for each
one in the process with a variety of
classes weapons and tech you'll be
looking for only the best of the best to
engage with your mission as the prey
however is a little bit more complicated
although you'll be playing as a member
of an elite fireteam your objectives in
the forest will be challenging enough
without considering the predator lurking
in the shadows you'll have to coordinate
and strategize your way to safety
without falling prey to the hunter good
luck so 5 years after the events of its
predecessor the Last of Us part 2
follows an older Ellie and Joel who have
finally found a life of peace among a
thriving community of survivors that is
until a violent event forces Ellie to
embark on a new journey and search for
vengeance justice and closure on May
29th you can experience this beautiful
but dangerous world for yourself and
thanks to the newest iteration of the
Naughty Dog Engine the characters and
world are more realistic and
meticulously detailed than ever before
at Paris games week 2017 Sucker Punch
Games announced their next project
following the successful infamous series
ghosts of Tsushima is a stealth action
adventure set in the 12th 70s you play
as Jin sekai one of the remaining
samurai defending the island of Tsushima
against the invasion of the Mongol
Empire since its announcement trailers
have revealed the artistic combats
and sprawling open world environment
Costa Tsushima will be launching this
summer from the developers of observe
the pathless is a single player
atmospheric adventure that will take you
through a world plagued by darkness
explore a mysterious curse island with
your eco companion as you bound
acrobatically through dense forests to
hunt prey and discover ancient ruins as
a graceful hunter moving through this
mystical world your skills and abilities
would be the key to conquering the
dangerous spirits lurking in the woods
with the unique take on the design of
archery intuitive gameplay and a
captivating atmosphere the pathless is
looking to hit the bull's eye when it
launches on ps4 this year yakuza returns
in 2020 with a fresh face and the
accuser like a dragon you play as
Ichiban cazuca a member of the Tojo
clans Arakawa family who serves 18 years
in prison after trying to work his way
up the ranks when released from prison
he ends up in Yokohama far from home in
a place where no one remembers him to
celebrate the series 15 anniversary a
combat overhaul has been introduced
combining its popular brawler elements
with a new turn-based battle system the
accuser like a dragon launches in Japan
on January 16th and worldwide later this
year which one of these games are you
looking forward to the most let us know
in the comments below and be sure to
LIKE and subscribe so you can catch all
of our future videos see you next time
you
[Music]